[Music]
acclaimed chef and milk bar founder
that's christina tosi is out with a
playful new cookbook
aiming to inspire a new generation of
young bakers it's called
milk bar kids only is the fourth
cookbook from this acclaimed pastry chef
who is a two-time winner of the
prestigious james beard award
that recognizes culinary excellence and
she is
excellent with a capital e vladimir
dutier sat down with ms tosi and learned
how her baking
is about more than just satisfying your
sweet tooth vlad good morning to you
again i remember when she was here in
the studio she's awesome
she's amazing and there's an interesting
phenomena that developed
when the coronavirus pandemic but forced
much of the country
to stay at home gail people became
reacquainted with their ovens
right they bake for themselves they bake
for family and friends it wasn't just
toilet paper and sanitizing wipes that
sold out of stores
but flour and yeast as well baking had a
moment in 2020
and chef christina tozi was there to
meet it
half a cup of light brown sugar this is
what you're looking for it's smooth it's
creamy
no one's mad at it it looks very
delicious when the country went into
lockdown in the early days of the
pandemic
christina tozi headed to the kitchen we
need to take that cake we need to break
it down a little bit
the renowned chef met her fans in their
homes
hosting a bake club on instagram live
and boy did you all get after brittle
yesterday
you made pistachio brittle pecan brittle
butterscotch brittle
what did you learn i learned that
the power of being imperfectly perfect
is what i call it or comfortably human
perhaps
is is the most powerful tool i have
that community is a really powerful
thing the power of a baked good
is real and we need it now in the harder
times more than ever before
tozi has embraced that power for more
than a decade
in 2008 she opened milk bar a bakery
serving treats with a twist
like cereal milk ice cream there are now
13
milk bar outposts around the country
tozie has authored
four cookbooks including her latest milk
bar kids only
i wrote this book before this year so
it's kind of just ironic that
this book of celebration of looking
at the world through the lens of a kid
being a kid and getting in the kitchen
baking and being empowered by it they're
all such
meaningful things that we need right now
for anyone looking for the hide the
veggies in the cupcakes cookbook
this is unapologetically not it the way
that i was raised was always with
desserts as conduit
a platter of cookies is not about you
crushing the whole platter right
oh now you're telling me you've been
doing it wrong
no i believe that baked goods
are invitations into people's lives
they're opportunities to
share joy and heart and emotion
and it's about sharing as much as it is
about consuming
and little moments of things
are always going to be good for you so
one of the pro moves of this treat
is you put sprinkles on the bottom of
the pan for tozie the kitchen has always
been about connection do you ever notice
that people love
watching people cook or bake
i love when people come and hang out
with me in the kitchen
the kitchen is like my happy safe place
my grandma always welcomed me in
and it was kind of the place where we
talked about stuff
like i think you i get the most out of
people that just come and like hang out
and i'm like hey what's up how's your
day
what's going on anything good happen
what about the bad stuff you want to
talk about the bad stuff
it happens right here despite its
challenges
2020 has also brought opportunity for
the milk bar brand
most of its stores have reopened there's
been a jump in the online sales of its
care packages
over 340 000 have shipped and you can
now find milk bar confections in the
grocery aisles of target and whole foods
still tosi is determined to hang on to
the small business charm
i use my tummy as my guide when we're
testing new recipes
but i try to always use my heart as my
guide everywhere else
even when making the biggest heaviest
business decisions
because at the end of the day milk bar
is an extension of me milk bar is an
extension of the people
that i work with and we're all humans
just trying to figure out how to show up
in the world
my tummy is my guide too even as it
expands josie
also listens to her roughly 200
employees after this summer's
nationwide cry for social justice
milkbar updated several of its policies
tosi's team members now have an
additional
paid time off for mental health and to
vote in the upcoming election
how about that yeah she's awesome yeah
she is awesome
she's right the power of baked goods is
real because i'm still trying to
counteract that power
from back in april and may when i was i
wrote that down too anthony
and i like what she said imperfectly
perfect and comfortably human
life is uncertain i always eat dessert
first
that was that was a magnet on my fridge
when i was a kid my mom had it up there
i still live by it yeah
it's amazing what i found it's amazing
what power a cinnamon bun can have
that's right
pandemic thank you vlad